سجل مؤشر معدل التضخم في السعوديه ارتفاعا
بنسبه
3.4% في يناير 2023 ذلك مقارنه بالشهر
المماثل من 2022 هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه
اشاره الى ان اسعار السكن والمواد
الغذائيه كانت هي الدافع الاكبر لارتفاع
المؤشر المزيد من الارقام مع الزميل
العنود العبدلي
وصل معدل التضخم السنوي في السعوديه
ارتفاعه للشهر الثاني على التوالي ليصل
الى 43
هذا ما اظهرت هيئه الاحصاء في بيانها
اليوم مشيره الى ان ارتفاع الحالي في معدل
التضخم جاء متاثرا بسته عوامل اساسيه فكما
نشاهد هنا مشاهدينا ارتفعت الايجارات
الفعليه للمساكن بنسبه سبعه وسبعه اعشار
في المئه في يناير 2023 هذا ارتفاع
مشاهدينا انعكس على زياده اسعار الايجارات
الشقق بنسبه 19 وثلاثه اعشار في المئه
الذي يشكل الوزن الاضخم في المؤشر ياتي
بعد ذلك ارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه
بنسبه
34% اما قسم النقل مشاهدينا فسجل ارتفاعا
بنسبه 83
وسجل قسم المطاعم والفنادق والاخر ارتفاعا
بنسبه وخمسه اعشار
اما قسم الترفيه مشاهدينا والثقافه فقد
شهد شهد ارتفاعا طفيفا بنسبه
21% واخيرا سجل قسم التعليم ارتفاعا بنسبه
ثلاثه وعشرين في المئه وعلى اساس شهري
مشاهدينا فقد سجل معدل التضخم في يناير
ارتفاعا طفيفا بنسبه عشرين في المئه
مقارنه بشهر ديسمبر 2022
بحسب بيان الهيئه فكما نشاهدينا مشاهدينا
ارتفعت اسعار الايجار بنسبه واحد في المئه
اما اسعار القسم الاغذيه والمشروبات فقط
ارتفعت بنسبه خمسه اعشار في المئه وقسم
المطاعم والفنادق ارتفع بنسبه ثلاثه اعشار
في المئه اما قسم السلع والخدمات الشخصيه
مشاهدينا فقد ارتفع هو الاخر بنسبه عشر في
المئه التقرير كشف عن ارتفاع في غالب قطاع
الاغذيه والمشروبات فيما تفاوتت اسعار
الانشائيه وقبل استعراض مشاهدينا اكثر
السلع غذائيه ارتفاعا نتابع معكم هذا
الاستطلاع من منافذ بيعها في السعوديه
والله انا ما اتوقع انها لها حدود ولكن
انها فرق واضح جدا وكبير
خصوصا بالاعوام الاخيره المواد
الغذاء 10% عن السنه اللي فاتت والله
ارتفاع الحقيقه كل سنه يزيد ما ادري ايش
اقول لك اقول لك يعني لو حسبته من سنتين
او ثلاث سنوات يعني ارتفاع ما يقارب 70%
ومن اراء الناس الى تقرير هيئه الاحصاء
الذي كشف عن ارتفاع بعض السلع الغذائيه
حيث جاء اكثرها ارتفاعا الدجاج المجمد
المحلي الذي ارتفع باكثر من 35 في المئه
فيما سجل البيض المحلي ارتفاعا بنحو ثلاثه
وثلاثين في المئه القمح المحلي مشاهدينا
كذلك وحسب تقرير الهيئه سجل ارتفاعا سنويا
باكثر من 12 في المئه واذا لاحظنا
مشاهدينا معدلات التضخم على اساس سنوي
خلال العام الماضي 2022 نجد ان اعلى نسبه
لتضخم سجلت بنهايه العام عند 33
مرتفعه من
21% في يناير فيما سجلت بقيه الاشهر كما
نشاهد هنا تارجحا ضمن خط صاعد نعم وزر
الماليه السعودي كان قد اشار الشهر الماضي
في منتدى دافوس الاقتصادي الى ان
سيتراجع في السعوديه بفضل الخطوات
الاستباقيه كما اضاف الجدعان بانه تم رصده
علامات على التضخم في شهر يوليو 2021 وتم
اتخاذ العديد من اجراءات لحمايه الاقتصاد
السعودي من تبعات هذا التضخم
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو استاذ الماليه
والاستثمار بكليه الاقتصاد بجامعه الامام
دكتور محمد مكن دكتور محمد حياك الله
الرابعه وش اللي دفع التضخم للزياده للشهر
الثالث على التوالي في السعوديه الى الان
وصلت الى 3.4%
طبعا كان هيئه الاحصاء يمكن اظهرت بشكل
واضح انه كان السبب الرئيسي خلف هذا
الارتفاع الى 3.4% مقارنه بنفس الفتره من
السنه الماضيه اللي هي فئه السكن
والكهرباء والغاز كان الارتفاع فيها
بحوالي 6.6% ارتفاع كبير واحنا نعرف انه
هذا وهذا الفئه بالتحديد السكن والكهرباء
والغاز تمثل 25.5% يعني من حجم المؤشر
العام بشكل كامل من مئه بالمئه تليها اللي
هي الاغذيه والمشروبات كان الارتفاع فيها
حوالي 4.2% انا اعتقد انه ارتفاع السكن
والغاز والكهرباء بحكم انه احنا عندنا
خلينا نقول يعني نمو في الاقتصاد بصراحه
ما هو مفاجاه بالنسبه لنا لاحظنا انه في
حتى يعني مؤشر مدير المشتريات لشهر ديسمبر
يعني كان حوالي
56.8% قبل كده احنا وصلنا الى حوالي يعني
58% طبعا هذا
50% فوق 50% واحنا في مرحله نمو في انتعاش
عندنا في الاقتصاد في الانشطه غير النفطيه
وما في شك انه احنا عندنا اليوم مدام انه
عندنا ولا بده يكون في عندنا نسبه تضخم
وهذا ما في شك ايضا يعني
يستدعي اقبال الكثير من الاشخاص على مساله
السكن والارتفاع الخدمات الكهرباء والغاز
في احد يقول لي دكتور انه عندنا مشاريع
اسكان كثيره وجالسه يعني يوميا يعلن عن
الاف الوحدات السكنيه في المدن الرئيسيه
بالتالي الارتفاع اليوم بهكذا شكل بهكذا
طريقه وبهذا كذا ارقام على علامات استفهام
هو لانه بالتحديد في فئه الايجارات يعني
لو لاحظت فئه الايجارات ارتفعت بحوالي 19%
واحنا عارفين اليوم في اقبال كبير حتى من
يعني غير السعوديين على المدن الرئيسيه
الرياض جدا لمكه وهي كانت الثلاث مدن
الرئيسيه اللي كان فيها ارتفاع اكبر في
مساله الايجارات 19% نعتقد يعني ما ننسى
انه في مدينه جده بالتحديد اليوم عندنا
مساله القضاء العشوائيات وبالتالي دفعه
كثير من الاشخاص يخرجوا من الاحياء اللي
عشوائيه وبالتالي في اكبر على مساله
الايجارات في الرياض احنا عارفين صراحه
الاقتصاد عندنا ينمو بشكل كبير جدا
وبالتالي
والشركات ايضا حتى تعديل في مقرات الاقليم
وهذا كله دفع الحقيقه ننتقل الى الرياض
قبل 202 الفيدرالي الامريكي لغز اخر في
التضخم يعني كلما رفع نسبه الفائده يا
دكتور وتوقعنا انه نسبه التضخم حتنخفض او
دعني اقول يعني المستويات التي يستهدفها
للانخفاض لا تتحقق فبالتالي هل نحن بصدد
زياده اخرى من قبل الفيدرالي الامريكي اما
ان الخطوات التي اخذها في داره الفيدرالي
الامريكي في في في رفع نسب الفائده لم تكن
كافيه
الحقيقه في الدراري الامريكي من شهر مارس
في عام 22 هو بدا بمساله تشديد في
السياسات النقديه
ويحاول ان هو يعني يصل لاهدافه
الاستراتيجيه بانه ينفع التضخم في
مستوياته الطبيعيه في الاثنين بالمئه صحيح
ان التضخم انخفض من اكثر من 9% يعني مع
زياده الفيدرالي الامريكي لمستويات
الفائده اليوم احنا نتكلم على اخر يعني
احصائيه في التضخم كانت 6.4 وكانت دون
المتوقع لانهم كانوا يتوقعوا انه يصل الى
6.2
الواضح انه الفيدرا الامريكي مستمر على
سياسته
اعتقد ممكن اعتقد انه في الاجتماع القادم
ان يكون هناك ايضا زياده في يعني في اسعار
الفائده مستهدفين ربما هذا يكون الرفع
الاخير او هم
بيحاولوا قدر المستطاع ان يرجعوا بمستويات
التضخم الى مستوياته الطبيعيه فبالتالي
ايضا الفيدرالي بيحاول انه هو يعني يوازن
ما بين النمو او خلينا نقول لا يدخل
الاقتصاد الامريكي في مراحل الركود وبين
النسب الفائده اللي ما في شك انه حيكون
لها اثر كبير وبخصوصا على الانشطه غير
النفطيه بخصوصي يا دكتور
بعض التصريحات دائما عن
التراجع المتوقع في في نسب التضخم في
السعوديه في 2023 ربما يمكن ابرز هذه
التصريحات من وزير الماليه
كيف يمكن للتضخم في السعوديه ان يتراجع
باختصار الاجراءات اللي اتخذتها الحكومه
من وقت مبكر يعني جعلت مستويات التضخم حتى
وان شاهدنا انه ثلاثه فاصل اربعه لا يدعو
للقلق الحقيقه 3.4 يعني انا اعتقد مقارنه
ولكن هو مقارنه بالمستويات العالميه احنا
اليوم امام يعني تضخم على مستوى عالمي
كبير جدا دول تجاوزت الخمسين بالمئه
الاحداث الجيو السياسيه لها اثر ايضا
المستوى الاسعار الطاقه
الجائحه كورونا لم يتم التعافي منها في
العالم بشكل كامل كل هذه الامور الحقيقه
حينما نشاهد الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
السعوديه من تح سقف لاسعار الطاقه في
السعوديه كان لها اثر جدا ايجابيا حفزات
اللي قدمتها الحكومه يعني المتوقع انه
خلال الفتره القادمه ان المملكه يعني هدف
عندها اساسي انها يتراجع مستويات التضخم
من المستويات اللي احنا بنشاهدها اليوم
وان شاء الله نحن نحقق اهدافنا مع يعني
خلينا نقول في النصف الاول حتى في عام 23
ان شاء الله مع انه العام التوقعات دائما
غير مبشره يعني فعلا سيكون عام صعب يعني
ما هو سهل اشكرك جزيل الشكر كان معي هنا
في الاستوديو استاذ الماليه والاستثمار
بكليه الاقتصاد بجامعه الامام دكتور محمد
مكاني شكرا يا دكتور